claimed musician in his own right of
course in the managing and artistic
director of Jazz at Lincoln Center he
joins us from New York City good morning
wenton first our deepest condolences to
you and and the family thank you so much
for being with us thank you so much as a
pleasure to be here good morning good
morning you you are able you had a
chance to talk to your dad a few days
before you lost him what was that
conversation like well it was normal you
know just teasing him and messing with
him but I went through his history for
some reason of all the gigs I had seen
and people people he played with he was
he was with it and he's you know I would
always kind of tease and mess with him
you just go yeah yeah say something
every night and then I got a couple of
people's names wrong and he was
correcting me it was upbeat
I'm sure yeah I'm sure you've been
thinking I'm sure you've been thinking a
lot about him in these days what was
what's one of your fondest memories of
your dad man of so many my father was
was so large he he would be I teased him
all the time about his plan so I would
act like I play the piano but I really
can't play and I would say man I'm
coming for your gig and I will play
something but I think my last the last
thing we talked about in the in this
conversation he told me he was reading
David blights book on Frederick Douglass
so I was telling him I was gonna beat
him to read mitt the end of it cuz I
would always just tease him in that way
and he said man I'm almost at the end of
it you know I said well I said I read
it'll be tell you what's it then he said
no man he'll tell me no don't don't do
that
and uh he was just always he's always
worth working on stuff and studying and
curious about stuff I told him I met
David and I said man is interested talk
to somebody who wrote a book and can
tell you what Frederick Douglass was
doing in the 1850s and go year by year
just off the top of his head and my
father he was he was very impressed with
that you've called him your North Star
what in your from your perspective what
do you think his legacy is gonna be I
mean he has hundreds of students and I
we all loved him the same he taught all
those students the same well like a big
extent
family and he was so full of things and
here's the others myself Center down in
New Orleans and in the Ninth Ward in the
community where he loved to be and uh
you know he left a lot of songs and he
played and he taught a lot of us not
just music you're gonna be hosting a
virtual concert tonight featuring
artists from around the world
what can the audience look forward to
we're gonna see some of the greatest
musicians in the world from their
culture and they did all these specially
for us and we have people from Pakistan
from Japan from from Brazil people like
Milton Jolanda Dianne Reeves is gonna be
there singing a great version of smile
we have fantastic young singers Camille
Thurman and Veronica Swift do a new
version of Yardbird Yardbird suite did a
new arrangement Richard Wilson we all
did it to jazz in Lincoln Center
orchestra we did it remotely that's
always interesting the wdr band from
Germany two dudes old martini from South
Africa's fantastic musicians Richard
Galliano everybody wanted to do this to
show that we are one in it we all have
the legacy of jazz and we share it
around the world it's gonna be very very
personal and touching people are talking
is very warm we have a lot of great
hosts to come on and talk about the
music's just a soulful tonight all right
when thank you so much for being with us
again our deepest condolences and and
respect on losing your dad he really was
a giant